change is difficult and you know we're beings that
like being comfortable in this comfort zone right
getting out of that comfort zone is hard and uh it
takes a lot of work and uh it takes a lot of trust
and conviction and it's one of the hardest things
i've had to do but when you get to the other side
of that yeah a understanding that you've never
really arrived you always have to continue to
work and we're flawed and there's an evolution and
uh keeping that humility and being grateful for
for that is important but yeah i mean look in
order to to do better things you do have to change
we have a problem as a generation i think right
now of denying gratification we want it right now
i don't want to work for 10 years ago i want two
years i want to be on instagram like that person
have two million followers and have like money
coming in people are fascinated and they're like
really into it and like they're like you know
they always ask me well how do you do that i'm
like well i mean i i work all the time and they
said when you work i'm like five in the morning
like five in one i would never do that i'm like
exactly that's that's why you're never going to
do it on a long enough timeline no one is willing
to do what i'm willing to do they will fall off
and life has just taught me that is the [ __ ]
gospel truth we talked about that the try harder
one more time they keep going one more time and
they keep going one more time and they just keep
dropping off until you're the last man standing
or woman whatever it is a thousand percent
and that's why when you said that i was like
that's intoxicating me that is that is the very
thing that my success is predicated on is i'm i'm
i'm relentless like let the full weight of that
word wash over you i am relentless i will not stop
i'm like the [ __ ] terminator don't go into the
selling business i'm gonna repeat that a second
time do not go into the selling business go into
the reorder business where your product is so good
that you know when someone buys it yeah they're
going to want to either use it again or recommend
it to somebody else if it's a one-time service
right that's the key to longevity any business
and developing a product you can have whistles
and bells but if it breaks the next day or doesn't
work sensationally you don't have longevity my dad
when he said okay you're going to go to houston
you're going to get a football scholarship okay
you're going to do this and you're going to
go to the pros okay you're going to go to
you're going to you're going to be an all-pro and
you're going to go to pro bowl okay you're going
to win the super bowl he told us that the week
we're getting ready patriots are undefeated you
already won the game son it's already done you're
going to win the super bowl like he never said if
and i grew up and i remember going wow my dad
never said if he truly always said when which
i don't know if he knew what he was doing i don't
think so i don't think he knew consciously what he
was doing but he programmed with by always telling
me when in my head if there's something i want
when it happens it's not if it's gonna happen life
is short but at the same time like yeah i think
there's it's a very american thing to get stuck
in this idea of like well if i grow up wanting
to do this and i go to college for that i have
to do that forever you know what i mean right
and it's the same with like athletes veterans all
this stuff like it's not true like you can do 17
different things and be really good at all of them
you know what i mean like you have to obviously
commit and like put the work in but it's never
too late i look for things that happen in magical
ways and i look for this it'd be interesting to
see if you felt this in racing because a lot of
surfers feel it you know i don't know about i
don't know anything about race car driving but
you know how like when you surf and you're looking
for that perfect wave and you can get in the zone
anytime you're doing any sort of sport like that
you really get into flow and what i look for when
having ideas are is this in flow is it easy and
magical things happen like you are in this system
of flow and and i just roll with it like okay
let's see what happens and that's what i look
for when it's hard and difficult i kind of go i
don't know about this right it's that's a sign to
me um doesn't mean you can't do it it just means
you don't have the universal flow backing you up
right you have two choices in life really as
you are as an adult you can choose optimism
this is this this this bottle of water here is not
full but i'm going to fill it up or you can choose
pessimism there's not enough water it's empty
and optimism i choose optimism every time because
i choose to want to be optimistic and i choose
to want to have good things happen so when they
happen i'm happy in that stage already if you
choose pessimism you're always thinking something
bad is going to happen and then when something
bad happens you've already chosen it white so now
you have it a second time right so pessimists you
get two wacks yeah optimism it's just optimistic
yeah if it happens you're like okay yeah pessimism
you're worrying about it half not happening and
then it doesn't happen and you're screwed right
it's a terrible way to go through life i agree now
it doesn't really matter life is going to be what
it is but if you choose optimism i guarantee you
you will make better choices you will understand
what happens to you better even if it's bad
and you like look at things sit back and say
okay you know i can handle this this is fine
my second bankruptcy 38 and invested all my
money in this amazing idea that was a dot-com
it wasn't my passion but it was a good idea again
no it wasn't alive for me but it was a recruiting
platform that matched a person's culture with a
company culture it was 20 years ahead of its time
but it was genius back then you know but anyway
the stock market crashed lost everything went
into a spiritual sabbatical and really i was done
i was really one of those moments where i got down
on my knees to god and i tried to kill myself when
i was 21 but after i had children a family i knew
that wasn't an option but i was like i'm done
like god you need to really take me because i
can't do this anymore i was exhausted from all the
pushing and striving and going through and then um
you know i started this path of you know i read a
man search for meaning by victor frankl and then
i was in byron katie's workshop loving what is
and i found peace and happiness within my being
for the first time in my life there was no desire
for money success anything i literally was just at
peace i didn't need money i didn't need wealth
before i thought i needed wealth in order to
be somebody right i thought if i could ever just
get rich then i will feel worthy within my being
so then poo-pourri came along and what
i realized is if i can lose everything
that i'm not going to do it the same way
i did it before i'm going to have fun
because when i lost everything when i was 38 i
looked back and i said what's worse than losing
everything is losing everything and realizing
you didn't even have a damn good time doing it
right i was exhausted i was burnt out you know
it was horrible so i didn't have anything so then
when i said if i'm going to go back in business
i'm just going to have fun that's it i'm just
going to have fun i'm going to go with the flow
if it feels good i'm going to do it if it doesn't
i'm not because the [ __ ] can just
get wiped out at any second so that
was when i began that philosophy i'm like if
it feels good do it and if it doesn't i'm not